hello everyone and welcome to the
biggest ideas in the universe this is
one of our Q&A sessions I'm your host
Sean Carroll and today we're going to be
doing the Q&A associated with idea
number three force energy and action so
as I go through these Q&A videos I am
moving away more and more from the idea
of specifically going down question by
question and more and more toward a
theory of using the questions to inspire
me to elaborate on things that maybe I
lost over or simply forgot to talk about
when I did the original video this is
the downside of having a very casual non
polished non rehearsed approach is it
sometimes there are things I wanted to
say and I just forgot to say them also
in this Q&A when you use the opportunity
a few people have asked how I actually
make the videos so I will be at the end
of this QA talking a little bit about
the setup and the technology that goes
into actually making the videos if you
want to stick around for that I thought
I would stick it at the end because many
of you couldn't care less so clean up in
other words what are the things that I
didn't talk about in the actual video
that I want to talk about them the most
important thing is nothing very profound
that I have to say but remember we were
talking about the Newtonian versus
laplacian paradigms right so here is a
particle at some point X this is X
naught naught 0 equals not that was
another question that was helpfully
answered naught is just a way of saying
zero and T naught okay and then at some
other time T 1 the particles located at
X 1 and in the least action way of doing
things we say of all the paths you could
traverse between X naught and X 1 and
between time T naught and T 1 what is
the one that minimizes this quantity
called the action and all I wanted to do
was to sort of highlight the question
how does it know this is the big issue
with the miraculous feeling that we have
about the principle of least action you
know so we're saying that I
don't tell you the initial velocity of
the particle I don't tell you the final
velocity I just tell you where it starts
and when it ends I tell you when it
starts and when it ends
and somehow the procedure for figuring
out all of the different ways of getting
from here to there is that had I gone on
another path that is not the actual
physical one the action this quantity
that we defined action is an integral if
that's okay the sum over all the
different moments of time of kinetic
minus potential energies over time okay
so and then you minimize the action you
get the least action to get the actual
path it seems like prec ignition is
going on here right it seems like the
particle leaves at point X 0 at time T 0
and it immediately has a velocity right
like there's some velocity that the
particle actually has right at that
moment and following that velocity in
the Newtonian paradigm we would say at
every moment we chug forward using F
equals MA and we get to the final point
but in this picture we say well it could
have taken other paths it could have
gone in other velocities and done other
things but then the this integrated
quantity called the action would have
been higher so it didn't take those it
took the one with the least action even
though the action is this non-local
quantity this quantity that can only be
evaluated by already knowing what the
path is right how did it know what what
to do so I don't want to there's no
answer to this in a simple way it's just
to point out that the question is badly
phrased you know it didn't know the
particle didn't guess the particle
doesn't think about every single path
ahead of time and then choose to go on
the path of least action there is a way
the particle moves and that way can be
specified by saying of all the paths it
is the one with the least action so one
way of thinking about this is you know I
said in words that minimizing the action
gives us the same
as the Newtonian way of doing things
starting with F equals MA but it's more
specific than that so let me talk about
minimizing a path what does it mean to
minimize something minimize the action
minimize in in math terms how do we find
the minimum of any function okay so
let's imagine we have a much simpler
function f of X as a function of X so
this is not X the positions just X some
variable we don't know what it is and
someone has a function that does
something like this how do we know where
the minimum of that function is well you
can see it there it is you and I can see
it just by looking but math can't see it
or a computer can't see it how would we
mathematically figure out where the
minimum is I can't I should have set
this a long time ago but the point is we
know that the slope of that curve is the
derivative the change in F as we change
X and the point about the minimum is
that at the minimum the slope the F DX
equals zero that's the mathematical way
of saying where the minimum is the
minimum is the point if it's a minimum
then at the minimum the slope is zero so
the derivative is zero so to solve for
the minimum mathematically you take the
function f you differentiate it you find
its derivative you set the derivative
equal to zero and then you solve that
equation that's an equation some
expression in terms of X the whole thing
equals zero you solve it you find the
minimum so that is what you do up here
of course for the least action principle
you take the action but the action is
not a function of one variable like X
it's a function of all the different
paths you could go on right here's
another path you could have gone on so
you have to do a much more complicated
integral this is the subject called the
calculus of variations the idea that you
have an infinite dimensional space the
space of all possible paths but
nevertheless you can find one path and
then take the derivative of some
quantity like the action as you change
the path by a little bit in fact the
mathematically rigorous way to define it
to basically turn that
infinite-dimensional thing into a
finite-dimensional thing where you just
change the path in one direction at a
time and set that equal to zero
everywhere so you can do this little bit
of calculus this little bit right here
look at this I'm learning to change
colors so this little bit of calculus
can be done on the space of all paths
not just on individual curves so that's
how you find the path of least action
but then the way that we do this how do
we there is a cute mathematical way of
letting you know that we're
differentiating with respect to an
infinite dimensional thing rather than a
finite dimensional thing which is that
rather than using the letter D for
derivative we use the Greek letter Delta
at the lower case Delta so the
functional derivative as we call it of
the action is written d s s is the
action I know if I said that I don't
know again why is two letter s use
there's probably some reason lost to
history but D s and I'm not gonna miss
Delta s for either Delta path so for
path I was gonna write the word path but
that's a little bit too casual even for
me
let me write X of T okay this is a fancy
language for simply saying we
differentiate with respect to all
possible paths that number called the
action we set that equal to zero and the
point is we get an equation okay we get
an equation and that equation turns
exactly into Newton's laws that's how
you prove the equivalence between the
least action way of doing classical
mechanics and the Newtonian way of doing
classical mechanics you have this
formalism that sounds very abstract you
have all these paths an infant
dimensional space of all the different
possible paths you figure out how to
differentiate with them there's a lot of
math involved you take math classes good
for you but at the end the equation that
comes out from minimizing the action is
the statement that at every single point
along the trajectory the particle obeys
Newton's laws of motion okay so that's a
way of
easing your anxiety about the fact that
the particle seems to know ahead of time
which path to take it's not that it
thinks about every single path and
chooses the right one is that the
condition that follow the path you
follow be the least action one is the
same as the condition that you're
obeying Newton's laws at every moment
okay that's one thing to keep in mind
here's another thing that you're
probably thinking already as you watch
me write these things sure the minimum
of this function has the feature that
its derivative is zero but guess what a
point where the function is a local
maximum also has that feature where the
slope is exactly zero so the condition
that the action have zero derivative
zero slope in the space of all possible
paths doesn't pick out the minimum
uniquely it just says it's a place where
the function isn't changing
instantaneously momentarily it could be
a minimum or a maximum or in higher
numbers of dimensions it could be what
we call a critical point where in some
directions it could be going down in
other directions it could be going up
but it's momentarily stationary so
sometimes this is called a saddle point
if you think of literally a saddle that
is sort of this kind of shape in two
dimensions right then if you you're
right here you're at a critical point
where everything is flat you're at a
flat location on the surface but in this
direction things are going up in this
direction things are going down right so
you're at a mixed point where in some
directions it's up some directions is
down but momentarily everything is
planned how do you know that the actual
path you're going to take is not just
some extremum some maximum or some
critical point rather than the minimum
the answer is you don't you don't know
that in fact that's fine a path where
the action was locally maximized would
be a perfectly good solution to the
equations of motion the problem is
that's what not what appears in nature
and the reason why is you can easily
make the action infinitely big right
just like jiggle infinitely fast very
very very quickly on very very small
timescales you can get as big of an
action as you want
it's
netic - potential just make your kinetic
energy really really big so practically
there is no such thing as a maximum of
the action it can be infinitely big
there is such a thing as a minimum at
some finite value that's where the
actual pads are that's why it's the
principle of least action not just the
principle of stationary action but in
principle as it were the principle could
say any any point where Delta s Delta
path equals zero is a perfectly good
solution to the equations of motion
formally speaking this also leads us to
the following idea even if you can rule
out Maxima you can certainly have
functions where here's another function
f of X versus X what if I have a
function looks like this
where there's lots of minimum locally
there's it sort of I didn't draw it very
well but probably this point is the
actual minimum but this point and this
point and this point all seem to be
minima locally right you're in the
bottom of a little valley and in fact at
every one of these points df/dx equals
zero there and there and there and there
and there so I can draw a zero better
than that I think so what about those
points you know can we imagine that we
might live there yeah you can in fact
that's no problem whatsoever think about
particle in a box
so here's now this is not space-time
anymore this is space and space so
here's X and y okay a box two
dimensional box and I have a particle
that starts here so this is X naught at
time T naught and I say I want the
particle to get to here point x1 at time
t1 okay and maybe Y is also different
for these two different things so
clearly there is going to be a path that
looks like this just goes straight
across and you go at some velocity so
given that when you leave you leave a
time T naught and when you arrive you
arrive at time t1 there will be a
correct velocity so the principle of
least action will find that correct
velocity for you
you how fast you need to go from there
to there but that's not the only path
that would get you there if you went
more quickly than that path you would
not go there because you would reach
there and then bounce back by the time
you reach t1 if you went more slowly you
wouldn't get there in time but you can
bounce off the wall at the correct angle
so this could be your path if you move a
little quickly it's a little farther
path but if you move more quickly so you
have a higher initial velocity than the
yellow path put an arrow in the o FF
also then that orange path is perfectly
allowed that is something that could
start you at X naught at T naught and
get you to x1 at t1 what's wrong with
that well the answer is nothing is wrong
with that that's a perfectly good path
and the principle of least action allows
you to take it so that is exactly this
situation this yellow path is one of the
points which is a minimum of the action
this orange path is another local
minimum of the action so the set of
trajectories that satisfies Delta s
Delta path equals 0 those give you all
the allowed paths and they would all be
found by this method so you see that
there's a little bit that's a little bit
of a disadvantage maybe to the principle
of least action versus the Newtonian
laplacian way of doing things did you
told me the Fosse way of doing things
gives you a unique answer almost always
there's some tiny little caveat to that
would you may get to later but starting
from a single point with a single
position in the single momentum you just
chug forward in time and you get a
unique answer minimizing the action
between two points at two different
times could give you multiple answers
maybe you consider that a bad feature
because you don't get a unique answer
but maybe it's good because you get a
whole bunch of good plausible answers
that's just how it is that is allowed
completely consistent by the principle
of least action good I did that I did
that so the last thing I wanted to
mention sort of as I in a clean up vein
is how much information is required
oops
because I said that it was the same
amount in the Newtonian point of view
versus the least action point of view so
if this is X this is T again one way of
doing it is you start here this is T
naught this is T 1 not a very well drawn
T 1 sorry about that so you say you've
been there this is X 1 comma T 1 X
naught comma T naught and I said look in
the Newtonian way you give me X naught
and P naught at this initial time in the
least action way you would give me X
naught and X 1 ok so you give me the
initial location in the final location
you don't give me any velocities or any
moment at all so I said it's an equal
amount of information this looks like a
one-dimensional line that the particle
lives on but if it lived in three
dimensions there'd be three pieces of
information three dimensions for the
position and also three for the momentum
so it still matches in both cases but
the question was asked yes but what
about the time that looks like here you
give me T naught and here you give me
both T naught and T 1 so that doesn't
look quite fair I get what you're saying
but it's not really an issue of course
in the Newtonian point of view you start
with X naught P naught and then you get
the entire path at all times in the
least action point of view you get
between T naught and T 1 but I could all
I could still ask the question from the
Newtonian point of view given X naught
and P naught given my starting position
and velocity where would I end up at T 1
if I started at T naught where would I
end up at T 1 that is the question being
answered by that point of view and the
least action principle that process
formalism answers the same question
given I started at X naught a T naught
and I want to end up at X 1 at T 1 what
is the path I take in between so
secretly it is exactly the same amount
of information either way don't worry
about that okay
now we get any more specific questions
that were asked in various places you
can ask questions either in the YouTube
video or on the blog you can try to ask
questions on Twitter but I might forget
them it might be hard to trace down when
I mentioned the blog by the way I'm
embedding all these videos at
preposterous universe com slash blog
this is my blog and I've kept for many
many years right now I'm using it as a
place to put these videos so you can ask
questions there there is actually the
best place to ask because there's many
more comments on YouTube that are not
just questions okay so here's a question
why this is the kind of question I like
people asking why is the action s equal
to the integral of kinetic - potential
energy oops
and in particular the kinetic energy is
one-half MV squared potential energy is
just some function V of X why is that
the action rather than something else
so the glib and completely 100% true
answer is that's what works that is the
formula that actually gives us the
behavior of particles in the real world
for particles like a point ball rolling
down a hill or something like that okay
but you but what you're really asking
then is well is there any principle
reason why I couldn't consider other
things why I couldn't consider the
velocity cubed or the velocity times the
position or something like that but the
answer is those would give you different
laws of physics this is the form of the
action
that gives you Newton's laws F equals MA
and then the various definitions of what
you mean by F for the electromagnetic
force or for the gravitational force or
whatever this is the right kind of
action but you're allowed to consider
other kinds of action in fact let me
tell you let me reveal you a secret not
really a secret let me reveal you a true
fact that is well ahead of where we are
in this discussion one of the
interesting things about this least
action way of doing it one of the
reasons why it's interesting even though
at the end of the day it just gives you
back
Newton's laws is that when you get to
more advanced more complicated more
subtle theories of physics like we have
in quantum field theory it becomes much
easier to write down an action than it
does to write down equations of motion
and I can tell you why that is so here
we wrote down the action as kinetic
energy minus potential energy for a
particle moving along a line we will
later on god-willing be later talking
about field theory so rather than
talking about a particle at some
position here is space and this is time
again remember always label your axes
there's so many professional scientists
who will draw plots and they know what
the axes are but they don't tell you so
give me a hard time if I don't label the
axes in field theory the fundamental
objects are not particles with locations
they are fields like Phi
it's a typical Greek letter that we use
for a field and Phi has a value at every
point in space and at every moment of
time so there's fine at that location by
dislocation over here etc it says it's a
that's what a field is unlike a particle
is defined by where it is a field is
everywhere but it's defined by how big
it is at every single point so something
like this formula we have for the
kinetic energy minus the potential
energy seems not up to the task because
it's a function of X and V the position
and velocity whereas here we can work
with Phi which is itself a function of
position and time and we can also work
with various derivatives of Phi so we
can work with the what we call the
partial derivative this is sorry too
much math here but now that Phi depends
on both space and time
rather than saying the derivative of Phi
we have to say the derivative of Phi
with respect to space and the derivative
of Phi with respect to time etc and so
we use these weird curly
I think it was like nuts invented these
to let you know that we're doing a
partial derivative a derivative in one
particular direction at a time in space
time so we have a whole bunch of things
that we can work at and every single one
of these is a function of both space and
time so the reason why this works so
nicely in field theory is the action S
is given by in our old formula or got a
way of doing it the integral of
something called the Lagrangian so we
wrote kinetic minus potential and that
was a particular that this function
kinetic energy minus potential energy is
what is called the Lagrangian and that
was for a point particle it looks like a
written Poh but I really haven't
potential in field theory the Lagrangian
itself L is going to be an integral of
some function some function of space
over all of space so at every point in
space I take these quantities the field
and its derivatives I construct some
function I multiply the field together
and multiply the derivatives of the
field together I do all these things
that I want to do and then I integrate
over all of space call that the
Lagrangian and then I integrate over all
time the Lagrangian I call that the
action so this function is called the
Lagrange density but because we are
always lazy and because we literally are
always working with the Lagrangian s'ti
we just call the lagrangian sativa
lagrangian so the technical careful
thing is that the Lagrangian is the
thing you put and integrate over time to
get the action the grunge density is the
thing you integrate over all space to
get the Lagrangian but we actually just
use the terminology informally that the
LeGrande enca T we call the Lagrangian
so the point is all of this is to say
the lagrangean to a particle physicist
with quantum field theories oops
yeah I had it right grunge Ian Curley L
it is often written and it is a function
of Phi and its derivatives the
derivative of Phi with respect to space
derivative of Phi with respect to time
and also the derivative other fields
because there's more than one field in
the world right so maybe you have a
field sigh I don't want to call the sigh
because that's the quantum wave function
that gets confusing ADA is a field and
ADA has derivatives with respect to
space and ADA has derivatives respect to
time and there's a large number of
fields and their derivatives okay so the
Gwangi is a function of many many things
but it's just one function it's just one
particular combination of all those
different fields if you have a huge
collection of fields then if you just
wrote down Newtonian looking equation of
motion every field would have its own
independent equation of motion whereas
in the Lagrangian way of doing things
you take all the fields you combine them
into some function to make a Lagrangian
you calculate from that Lagrangian the
action you minimize the action where to
go
Delta s equals zero right there you go
you minimize this action and that's all
of your equations of motion because
you're minimizing it with respect to
field one Phi and then field to Ada and
then field three Omega or whatever it is
you separately minimize this function
the action with respect to all the
fields and all those separate
minimizations give you different
equations of motions so if you go down
here what you would say is that Delta s
Delta Phi equals zero Delta s Delta ADA
equals zero so from one function the
Lagrangian you get all the different
equations of motion that's an enormous
increase in simplicity and power and so
what that means is
you're guessing new theories of nature
when your being a modern particle
physicist or quantum field theories the
thing that you're doing is writing down
new lagrangian so you're inventing new
fields and you're inventing new ways for
them to interact with each other if you
talk about the higgs boson what did
higgs and his friends on glare and Brout
and others actually do they wrote down a
new lagrangian for a new field and they
showed that this music Ranjan would lead
to certain new features of the world
like breaking the symmetries and things
like that and then many years later that
actual prediction that there was a
particle associated with that field was
discovered in the Large Hadron Collider
so one of the reasons why lagrangians
and therefore actions are so important
is that the job of the modern quantum
field theories is to write down the
right lagrangian of the world at least
to the extent that quantum field theory
of the right description of the world so
far we think it is but there's some
hints from gravity and other things that
maybe it's not complete but anyway this
is how modern cutting edge field
theorists think they think in terms of
lagrangian's that's what I wanted you to
know so sorry about you know this got
mathy sorry about that I don't wanna get
to Matthew the point is the least action
principle is not just a cool twist on
Newtonian mechanics it's an
extraordinarily powerful tool in modern
physics so we use it all the time but
there's another reason I'm not gonna go
into it too much right now but the other
reason why the grungy ins and the action
are great is because they let you
implement symmetries very very simply if
you have symmetries like remember
Galilean invariance right doesn't matter
where you are or how fast you're moving
you can write down lagrangians that
respect those symmetries and then the
equations of motion will respect them
automatically
so again just because the single
function lagrangian is a much simpler
thing than a long list of equations of
motion it's a much more compact powerful
way of thinking ok another question was
quantum mechanics because look when I'm
drawing pictures like this which I've
now drawn over and over again X T Point
point path but then also other paths
there's another path there is another
path ok many many little paths doing
different things that's the picture that
you draw associated with the principle
of least action and then the thing that
you say is the there's only one of those
actual paths that is taken the one where
the men action is minimized but you've
probably heard of Fineman richard
fineman some over histories what Fineman
realized was that in quantum mechanics
you know in quantum mechanics what we
talked about in the traditional way of
talking about it is forget about
particles forget about positions we have
a wavefunction schrödinger's wave
function we evolve it forward or
backward in time those of you who are
not familiar by my book something deeply
hidden I'll write that down something
deeply hidden you can read about this ah
I have to write the word correctly my
own book write something to be honest I
think that the sum of our histories is
only mentioned very very briefly I don't
try to explain it in this book but
quantum mechanics and wave functions the
traditional way of doing it I definitely
do
explain it great length so if you want
the traditional way read that book the
sum of our histories way is you know
even though what we care about is the
wave function let's pretend that what we
care about is a particle
okay let's care about there let's let's
pretend there really is a particle let's
pretend the particle really has a
location in space as a function of time
and let's pretend that there's all these
different paths it could take and let's
say let's imagine that because it's now
quantum mechanics not classical
mechanics that it takes all of the paths
that the actual quantum evolution of the
particle is that all of these paths are
actually taken but when we take all
these pans what we do is we calculate
not the acting we calculate the action -
- all those paths but we're not done yet
we don't just minimize the action we add
up a contribution and again this is a
little more math and you need we write
down a contribution e the number
e to the power I squared minus 1 times
the action this is the number that we
integrate over all paths we sum them up
that's what sum means integral and some
are the same thing an integral is just a
continuous version of the discrete sum
so this is an integral over all paths of
this number e to the I times the action
what this means is that when the action
is near a minimum right when it's near
its location that is classically allowed
the least action path paths that are
almost at least action paths but not
quite will give all most of the same
action right if it's if the derivative
of the path of the action is 0 that
means that nearby paths have almost the
same action so near the classical path
this number s is almost the same for
nearby pads and therefore when you add
them up they constructively interfere
they give you the same kind of
contribution but this number e to the is
it's a complex number so it has a real
part and imaginary part both the real
part and the imaginary part can be
either positive or negative so once you
get far away from the real true
classical pads even paths that are very
near by each other can have wildly
different actions and because they have
wildly different actions typically when
you add up e to the I times the action
you get a big positive number from one
path and a big negative number from
another path they will destructively
interfere
so what Fineman says is that in quantum
mechanics you actually can imagine the
particle taking all the paths but the
classical paths count more or say that's
slightly more rigorously inaccurately
the set of all paths near the classical
path count more than the set of all
paths far away from the classical path
and one way of interpreting this is the
particle probably did what it did
classically or near to classically but
there is a probability that the particle
does something very surprising this is
exactly the relationship of Fineman sum
over histories to ordinary quantum
mechanics using
Schrodinger equation is exactly the same
as the relationship between the
principle of least action in classical
mechanics and Newtonian way of doing
classical mechanics namely they do
exactly the same predictions there is no
empirical difference they are two
different formalisms that give you
exactly the same physical theory just
two different sets of words assigned to
the same phenomena so it's not that one
is right and one is wrong but you can
get insight from thinking about things
in different ways just like I said you
can get insight it's a powerful
formalism to use actions and
lagrangian's in quantum field theory
rather than a newtonian way of doing it
you can get insight from thinking about
transitions between different quantum
states from a sum over history's
perspective rather than a Schrodinger
equation perspective so it is not a
mistake it is not an accident it's not a
coincidence that the pictures we drew
when we explained the principle of least
action are the same pictures you draw
when you draw Fineman sum over histories
in a way I mean when Fineman himself
tells it this is kind of what he was
inspired to think of from Dirac Dirac
was the first to use the action
formalism at all in quantum mechanics
but he didn't quite go all the way and
Fineman said can we think about this as
you know all the pads and directs it
yeah you can try and then he did and he
invented this so it's a very nice way of
thinking about things okay that was one
legit question very very good question
another one is you know so phase space I
said the space of all initial conditions
right the space of all the data you have
to tell me do what to know what the
particles gonna do next is this face of
positions and momenta okay so people say
well what about things like the mass of
the particle or the charge of the
particle or other parameters the spin
something like that okay there are
certainly other features that you need
to know and this is certainly true I
mean that's absolutely correct if you're
in an electric field for example if you
have an electric field pointing this way
here's an electric field pointing up
okay and you have a particle here
that has charge Q and Q is greater than
zero so you have a positively charged
particle that particle will start
accelerating will feel a force going
upward if you have another particle I'll
make it another color at the same
location I'm not going to draw it at the
same location but in the same electric
field with the same magnitude of charge
but a negative amount okay a minus
charge oops I should have drawn that
better than this
then that will also feel a force but the
force will be in the other direction
okay so two particles at exactly the
same position with exactly the same
momentum can be pushed in different
directions and therefore travel on
different paths depending on with their
electric charges likewise the mass of
the particle will affect its
acceleration and so forth so yes you
need all those numbers the mass in the
chargin etc to give me the information I
need to chug forward in time and solve
the equations and get what trajectories
actually taken but when I say that the
force acting on some particle depends on
the positions and the velocities the or
the momenta of all the other particles
the way it depends depends on the masses
and the forces etc so secretly I might
you know imagine that built into this
function is knowledge of what the mass
is in charges etc are so it's a sloppy
way of talking I absolutely agree to
that and there's no defense for it but
it's something that you know I should
have noticed but is built-in once you're
a practicing physicist the phase space
things the position in the momenta those
describe the same system but in
different configurations in different
ways of starting out if you change the
mass or the charge then you're
describing a different system right so
when we say that the phase face is the
set of all possibilities we mean for
that specific system and we look at
physics sort of one kind of system
versus another kind of system and when
we say the phase space is all the
different ways the system can go we're
keeping the parameters of the system
fixed so you're absolutely right you
need to understand what
masses and charges are but implicitly
I'm building that into what I count as
the laws of physics in this particular
case so I don't know if that's a
satisfying answer but that is the answer
that is what we mean okay final
substantive question is what about the
Higgs boson I just mentioned it the
Higgs field so you may have heard that
there's something called the Higgs boson
the Higgs boson is a little vibration in
the Higgs field the whole point where
maybe we'll get there I don't know but
all of space is suffused with this
invisible energy field called the Higgs
field and you may have heard that
interactions with that field give
particles mass so I said that there are
things like the here's a particle with a
mass there's the gravitational mass
there's the inertial mass and so forth
there's different notions of mass the
question is where does the Higgs come in
is that a different kind of mass would
we not have F equals MA if it wasn't for
the Higgs field right so the answer is
the Higgs field determines the masses of
certain particles in fact determines
masses of or effects anyway influences
the masses of elementary particles this
is important what I mean by that is you
know the electron quarks things like
that so if the Higgs boson was not a
field pervading all of space the values
of the mass of the electron the mass of
the up quark the mass of the muon etc
would be different values they would
still be something called madness it's
just the value of the mass would be
different in particular if it was empty
space but you removed the Higgs field
the electron would somehow have zero
mass would be a massless particle but
it's not that the Higgs field has
anything fundamentally to do with the
nature of mass the essence of mass
Newton didn't need to know about the
Higgs field to talk about mass nor did
the introduction of the Higgs field
centuries later
change what we meant by mass it just
changes the value it helped
the value in the actual standard model
of particle physics now that's in fact
only true for elementary particles so
you and I right we're made of atoms so
we have roughly speaking here are
protons and neutrons okay so maybe this
is an atom some protons and neutrons and
then there are electrons going around it
and we will later or use a terrible
picture because it ignores quantum
mechanics but okay we'll give it more
electrons they give it three electrons
to make it electrically neutral the
protons and neutrons in your body or way
heavier like almost two thousand times
heavier the mass of a proton I'm not
going to get it exactly right the mass
of a proton in cosmologists units the
mass the proton is approximately the
same as the mass of a neutron which is
approximately 1,800 times the mass of an
electron so protons and neutrons are way
heavier then electrons are most of your
mass comes from protons and neutrons but
protons and neutrons are made of quarks
so proton equals two up quarks and one
down quark
whereas a neutron equals one up quark
and two down quarks and you can go home
and try to figure out therefore what are
the electrical charges of the up quark
and the down quark the answer is an up
quark is plus two-thirds the down quark
is minus one-third this works out okay
but interestingly the up quark and down
quark are nowhere near one third of the
mass of the proton and the neutron you
might think and that's the proton is
approximately the same as mass of the
neutron they're both made of three
quarks the masses must be one-third each
that's not true the mass of the Nutri of
the up quark and down quark tend to be
much less than the mass of the proton
and neutron how can that be possible so
the up quark and down quark get their
mass from the Higgs field but the up
quark and down quark are not where the
mass of the proton or neutron come from
why not the answer is this is
complicated not gonna do the whole thing
but the individual quarks have a color
this is their version of electric charge
they have a color charge and it's just
like the electron and a proton pull each
other in the atom because of
electromagnetism the quarks pull on each
other inside the proton and neutron
because of the color force QCD quantum
chromodynamics but the difference is an
electron all by itself has an electric
field that radiates to infinity and it
that electric field has energy in it but
it's a lot of energy when you're near
the electron and very very little energy
when you're far away if you had a single
quark all by itself in the universe it
would have a color field around it that
would contain an infinite amount of
energy this is why you don't ever have a
single quark all by itself in the
universe because quarks are confined
quarks can only exist inside protons and
neutrons and other versions of them
baryons and mesons hadrons so the reason
why is because if you have multiple
quarks their fields can cancel each
other out very very far away in fact the
color fields of the quarks in a proton
cancel each other out very quickly once
you get far away from the proton so
their energy the energy contained in the
color fields goes to zero very very
quickly but you're left with a little
ball called the proton which has these
little tiny dots in it called quarks and
a whole bunch of leftover color force
and energy
most of the energy inside a proton comes
from the energy in the color field not
the individual quarks that's very
different from an atom in an atom there
is energy that comes from the
electromagnetic field that contained
that that holds an electron to a proton
but that amount of energy is negligible
compared to the mass of the electrons
and protons themselves for the proton
it's the other way around
most of the energy and therefore most of
the mass of the proton comes from its
color fields and that has nothing to do
with the Higgs boson whatsoever it's a
completely different phenomenon so even
though most of the mass of elementary
particles comes from the Higgs
ultimately most of your mass does not
most of your mass comes from QCD quantum
chromodynamics
the color charge that holds the quarks
together in a proton and the neutron
that's the relationship such as it is
between the mass within the Higgs and
the mass of other things will probably
say all this again in a later video okay
that's all I had for the physics
questions I had a very brief
introduction to how I actually make
these videos you know I'm still learning
I'm still trying to be better at it so
the simple thing is it none of this is
simple I'm sure there's a simpler way of
doing this then what I do it then how I
do it so I have a program called
Camtasia which does two things it
captures video from the computer screen
oops I can do better than that
so I have a laptop which is a Mac and I
can have images on the laptop and
Camtasia can capture them in video form
okay and it also lets me edit it's a
simple video edit editor so I can cut
and snip and things like that and also
green screen out so Camtasia is good for
that it that's what I wanted I wanted
something that could capture from the
screen and also could get rid of the
green screen behind me Camtasia does
that some very very simple audio editing
features and color editing features
things like that now ideally that would
be almost everything right I need to be
able to get the things that I'm writing
here on the pad onto the screen somehow
so I have an iPad iPad with a program
called notability and pencil Apple
pencil as I mentioned I don't know why
they don't call it a pen but they call
the Apple pencil so that's how I'm
writing on this pad here it is
here's the iPad that I'm writing on oops
by changing it my screen switched so I
can write on here I can take notes I use
a program called Notes Plus when I'm
actually taking notes we're doing
calculations or things like that I use
that for the first few videos but it
doesn't have this dark mode capability
it doesn't have this dark background so
notability as opposed to Notes Plus has
this dark background is otherwise a very
similar kind of arrangement so what I
need to do is to get the thing I write
on the iPad to the screen of my laptop
so that Camtasia can capture it that's
simpler than it looks actually it's just
QuickTime so QuickTime which you already
have if you have a Mac and I'm sure
there's some windows version or Linux
version or whatever QuickTime Player
you can fire that up and there will be
an option new movie recording and you
click on new movie recording and the
default is it looks through your webcam
to try to record a movie but you can
change
that default to capture from your iPad
so in principle you could do that over
wireless or Bluetooth I use an actual
cord to do it cuz I don't use a wire and
trust the wireless for this but the
point is there can be a window on my
laptop that is mirroring what's
happening on my iPad
Camtasia can capture that simultaneously
Camtasia can capture what is happening
in my webcam part of the reason why the
early videos were not as good in terms
of color and and focus and things like
that is because the webcam was just not
up to it and it's not just the my
computer webcam I had a fancier webcam
that was external but it still wasn't up
to it so eventually I switched to using
a Canon camcorder Vixia camcorder and so
I used that to actually make the videos
and then I just import them separately
and it's a pain in the butt
but I love you folks so much I'm willing
to do it for you so I need to separately
import the video using these little
flash drives to the computer and then
read them into Camtasia and then sync up
the audio and stuff like that but that's
very doable I'm kind of used to doing
equivalent things from doing the podcast
okay I made a mistake and I got a
camcorder that does not have remote
control so I have to walk over it and
push the button and then come back but
that's up that's a minor thing and then
I also have a separate microphone
because I'm a podcaster I have a podcast
mindscape you should all check it out so
I have a fancy podcasting microphone way
more than I need here it is this is an
electro voice our e320 microphone that I
take the audio in I think that the audio
quality probably less important for
youtube videos then for podcasts but
that's okay I can use that it goes right
in there's a little machine that brings
it in from that to the computer but
that's okay Camtasia can bring that in
perfectly well okay and then I put it
all together and that works I think
that's all the software I'm using the
other question is the actual physical
studio setup so studio
here it is one of these directions
oh my left shoulder right shoulder I
don't know because what I'm gonna do is
as I'm editing this video and I'm going
to use Camtasia to import a picture of
the studio set up so it's not a very
complicated studio setup it's my office
I don't have a lot of room but what I
did was I went to Sammy's camera
Sammy's with one M which is a chain that
has stores in throughout California
there's one in Pasadena near Cal Tech so
I had no idea what I was doing I knew
that I want to do these videos with a
green screen and honestly I don't need
the green screen I could just do it in
my office but I need to keep myself
entertained somehow so I thought that'd
be a fun extra thing to learn so I went
in to Sammy's camera and I explained
what I wanted to do and there was a
woman working there who had been a
portrait photographer and she knew
exactly what I was talking about and she
said well you need this and this and
this and you know you see these lights
with the umbrellas and everything and
the green screen is pretty big and I
needed a big setup a pole to hang the
green screen oh and I'm like wow this is
way more than I thought it was gonna be
she explained all why I would need it
and she turned out to be completely
correct so I kind of didn't believe her
but you know as you know the video
quality has improved over the past few
videos because I was learning more and
more about the lighting setup you have
to light the green screen brightly
without lighting yourself too brightly
but you have to light yourself so you
don't look pink or anything like that
and it turned out that what I eventually
learned by trial and error is what she
was trying to tell me all along so I'm
sorry I forgot your name person from
Sammy's camera who helped me out but I
went there literally like three days
before we went into lockdown here in Los
Angeles and the store closed so after we
already knew after restaurants had
already closed but before other stores
had closed I didn't trust myself to buy
things correctly on the internet I
wanted to talk to a real person so I
went there and she told me what to buy
and I just decided to accept her wisdom
there and I bought it and so it's
turning out pretty well
there yeah there's a lot of tricks there
like not only do I have to worry about
what color I'm wearing but
so if I wore green obviously that would
be bad but I've been on you know videos
before I've been on you know Nova and
The History Channel and through the
wormhole with Morgan Freeman and when
you're on green-screen they tell you not
to wear black and I never quite
understood that but now I get it like
somehow it's not that black is the same
as green but that the adjustment there's
a exposure adjustment that happens if
you're too dark it over exposes the
green behind you and becomes harder to
remove or at least that's my current
interpretation of it so anyway that's my
setup then why am I forgetting anything
important here you know a bunch of
little drives and and everything I'm
still struggling with the fact that the
videos are huge file sizes like 60
gigabytes is the Camtasia file when it
finally outputs an mp4 that I can upload
to YouTube it's smaller than that but
the working you know Camtasia format is
really really big and it I don't think
it should be that big and it's a
struggle to put it on my computer with
the disk space but I'm learning about
that anyway probably not many of you
wanted to know that but I'm glad someone
asked this is where I'm gonna put it so
if anyone wants to know they can look
there as I've said before I hope you are
enjoying it I am enjoying making it it's
it takes time but it's useful time it's
good to think about this stuff and it's
good to you know distract yourself a
little bit I like you know I could just
play video games or watch movies all day
this is enormously more rewarding than
that so thank you very much for watching